[Music]
on this Friday night tens of millions of
jobs across North America gone the
growing collateral damage from kovat 19
wits priority right now do I pay my
mortgage or do a Google search avi
what's needed to rev up the economy
operation restoration it becomes very
difficult for us to stay with confidence
don't worry it's okay to wait the
expanding backlog of surgeries the case
builds against a Canadian fashion mogul
more women accused Peter Nygaard of
sexual abuse plus somber and subdued
celebrations honoring courage and
sacrifice on the 75th anniversary of VE
Day
[Music]
global national with Donna freezing
tonight
Robin Gil good evening and thank you for
joining us we begin tonight with a
staggering look at the state of Canada's
labor market the impact of the Cova 19
shutdown has led to some of the worst
unemployment numbers in this country's
history nearly 2 million people lost
their jobs in April that's a record and
that's on top of the more than 1 million
people put out of work in March Canada's
jobless rate has soared to 13 percent
temporary layoffs account for nearly all
of the job losses women are still the
most affected but the gender gap
narrowed in April provinces are slowly
reopening their economies but as abigail
Beeman reports it will take time to
recover
Sarah Turner is spending more time with
her son Te'o she's one of millions who
lost her job due to kovat 19 now getting
the Canada Emergency Response benefit
it's been fairly seamless yeah and and
hopefully at some point soon I'll be
back at work but in the interim I'm
staying at home turner says it's hard to
wrap her head around the statistics
another two million jobs lost in April
millions more having hours or salaries
slashed
she's a coffee shop cook part of the
service industry hit first and hit hard
the April numbers show the losses spread
to goods producing sectors construction
manufacturing these numbers are historic
we've not seen anything like this not in
the last great recession we had and not
in the Great Depression of the 1930s
only half of Canadians are now at work
professor miles Korach says consumer
confidence and how well we handle the
pandemic are big factors in determining
how the economy bounces back we flipped
around entirely from a high pressure
high demand high work economy to a low
work installed economy just in two
months the prime minister now promising
the wage subsidy will be extended past
the original June date Justin Trudeau
says as people slowly head back to work
that will be used more than the
emergency response benefit to businesses
hit by kovat 19 know this
the wage subsidy will continue to be
there for you to help you keep your
employees on the payroll
like many Turner is anxious to get back
on the job I guess we'll just wait and
see what happens
because the day-to-day interaction with
customers was always one of the
highlights of my job so it will
definitely be different with provinces
rolling out gradual reopening plans so
many Canadians are expecting to be back
on the job as different as it may look
in the next few months but experts say
whether they stay there is a different
question and it's a waiting game to find
out whether these huge losses are
temporary after all
Robin avigal Beaman in Ottawa in the US
today's unemployment numbers are the
most grim in history over 20 million
people lost their jobs in April that's
more than 10 times the previous record
said in 1945 after the Second World War
ended as Jennifer Johnson reports many
families are now struggling to get food
on the table the US Labor Department is
reporting staggering job losses in April
twenty point five million Americans
forced out of work the greatest monthly
job loss in history as the Cova 19
pandemic strangles America's economy and
White House officials have no idea when
businesses may start to rebound I don't
want to give anybody a false sense of
anything I mean I say with with great
humility and deference you know these
are heartbreaking numbers America's
unemployment rate now stands at fourteen
point seven percent a level not seen
since the Great Depression over 33
million people have lost their jobs
since the pandemic started the virus has
forced businesses small and large to
close some permanently I really don't
know how I'll get by how I'll be able to
buy groceries a concern million share a
new Brookings Institute study shows
nearly one in five American mothers are
reporting their children aren't getting
enough to eat it's a lot I'm a single
parent I have a mortgage I have a car
note so you kind of think like what's
priority right now
do I pay my mortgage or do a Google
search off a across the country food
banks are overwhelmed people forced to
wait for several hours to get free food
I've never seen anything like this
Congress has not yet taken up a second
economic stimulus bill lawmakers are
divided about passing another massive
bailout package we've already spent you
know close to three trillion dollars
we've got understand somebody's gonna
pay that our kids our grandkids Congress
has temporarily bailed out the airline
industry through the end of September
airline officials warn a people don't
start flying again
tens of thousands will be laid off in
October we are gonna have to make some
decisions to reduce the size of our
reduce the cost that were paying even
with most states starting to reopen
Americans are reluctant to leave their
homes the fear of Koba 19 crushing
America's confidence and its economy
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
US Vice President Mike Pence's press
secretary has tested positive for the
new coronavirus Katie Miller is also the
wife to top Trump aide Stephen Miller
though Trump says he hasn't come into
contact with her six people who had been
in contact with the press secretary were
removed from a flight with pence just
before it took off today Miller is the
second person in the White House complex
known to test positive this week here's
the breakdown of cases in Canada over
65,000 people have been infected with
Kovan 19 and more than 4,000 people have
died from the virus in this country
Quebec is still the hardest hit
but Ontario recorded a significant spike
today its biggest in six days cases in
that province are up 477 since yesterday
some more than 19,000 people have tested
positive in Ontario another 63 people
died in Ontario in the last 24 hours
with the death toll now at over 1,500
the pandemic has hit the frontlines hard
more than 3,000 health care workers are
infected with Cova 19 that's more than
the total number of confirmed cases in
BC Nova Scotia and Saskatchewan doctors
nurses and other hospital staff right
across Canada have put so much on the
line by facing this pandemic head-on and
their critical work is paying off we're
now beginning to see plans for provinces
to resume elective surgeries canceled to
prepare for Cova 19
but the backlog is huge and as Heather
York's West reports it's likely to be a
long road ahead Gerry Wiesenfeld has
waited for years for knee replacement
surgery but days before he was scheduled
to go under the knife he learned his
procedure had been cancelled I guess
they have to take care of people who are
in far worse shape than I am the Cova 19
pandemic meant thousands of elective
surgeries had to be put on hold
BC officials counted 30,000 missed
procedures in that province alone with
kovat 19 infections now waning bc's
chief medical health officer says the
time is right to get BC surgeons
operating again we can now safely assume
that most patients do not have kovat 19
and that allows us to change the
protocols and to make them no less safe
but certainly a little more streamlined
elective surgeries have restarted or
will soon resume and many other
provinces across the country as well but
getting through the backlog won't be
easy even to get back to the normal
capacity in normal times we're not able
to do that yet because we still have
staff who are involved in caring for
Cobra patients they might be redeployed
to long term care and we also have these
supply chain problems for personal
protective equipment for drugs there's a
lot of moving parts some patients may
not be able to safely wait much longer
over the last two months
urgent cancer surgeries have continued
the concern now is that those other
cases may have progressed the patients
who may not have appeared very urgent
who in normal times would have a wait
time of about three weeks or four weeks
to have their cancer out are now into
the six weeks eight weeks wait time and
that's where we lose predictability of
the disease and so there is little time
to waste
ramp up surgery again or risk having
this pandemic claim even more lives
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
one of the largest poultry plants in
Canada is dealing with an outbreak of
Cova 19 tonight an employee at Maple
Lodge farms is speaking out about the
conditions inside the facility at least
25 workers at the Brampton Ontario plant
have tested positive for Cova 19 one
person has died Global News spoke with
an employee today and we have a
not to reveal this person's identity for
fear of reprisal the worker says maple
Lodge Farms is not providing enough PPE
to keep staff safe it's sketchy you can
have it to anyone now you don't
workplace they keep the plan all because
uh they want to keep candy this like
food itself but at the same time on the
workers are just as important if not
more Global News reached out to Maple
Lodge farms for a response in a
statement the company says Public Health
and the Ministry of Labour are the
authorities of public and workplace
health and both are satisfied with our
preventative plan and the measures we
have implemented to keep our employees
safe as Europe starts relaxing
restrictions Russia is emerging as the
latest kovin 19 hotspot cases and deaths
are surging and the numbers are
staggering for a sixth straight day
Russia confirmed 10,000 people were
infected with Cova 19 in just 24 hours
bringing the total number of cases to
more than a hundred and eighty-seven
thousand Russia is now the fifth most
affected country in the world 1,700
people there have died the world is
watching just how fast Cova 19 is
spreading around the globe there are now
more than 4 million confirmed cases of
Cova 19 worldwide and more than 275
thousand people have died Mexico
recorded its highest daily toll with
more than 1,900 new cases brazil one of
the world's emerging coronavirus
hotspots registered more than 5,300 new
cases according to a study by the World
Health Organization up to 190,000 people
could die of Cova 19 in Africa in the
first year of the pandemic if no
containment measures are taken the UN is
sounding the alarm on the rise in hate
and xenophobia the world body
secretary-general says migrants and
refugees have been vilified as a source
of copán 19 antonio guterres says the
virus does not care who we are and where
we live Andy's call
for an all-out effort to end hate speech
globally the pandemic continues to
unleash a tsunami of hate and xenophobia
scapegoating and scaremongering
anti-foreigner sentiment has surged
online and in the streets and the
Semitic conspiracy theories have spread
and covered 19 related anti-muslim
attacks have occurred and at least one
Canadian city has reported a disturbing
increase in hateful incidents the
Vancouver Police Department says 20
anti-asian hate crimes have been
reported to police so far this year in
comparison there were 12 anti-asian hate
crimes reported in Vancouver all of 2019
and police do note that many people
choose not to report the Alberta
government is promising 147 million
dollars to help residents rebuild after
severe spring flooding northern
communities like Fort McMurray are
mopping up after ice jams caused the
Athabasca and Clearwater rivers to
overflow 13,000 people were forced to
flee their homes premier Jason Kenney
says Albertans are tough but need help
we never have to go it alone in this
province albertans
always come through for each other and
so it is again this year
the funding is on top of the nearly
eight million dollars in emergency flood
payments already provided to vacuous
it's estimated there is a hundred
million dollars in damage Nova Scotia is
grieving families could get their day in
court
coming up the class-action lawsuit being
proposed after last month's rampage plus
the multiplying allegations of sexual
abuse against a Canadian fashion
executive
the number of women accusing Canadian
fashion mogul Peter Nygaard of rape and
sexual assault has grown since a
class-action lawsuit was filed in New
York State in February
46 women have come forward that list
includes 18 Canadians but as Mike
Armstrong explains there may be more
than that there were only ten plaintiffs
when the suit against Peter Nygaard was
launched barely three months ago since
then 36 more women have stepped forward
the recently amended lawsuit against the
fashion mogul is now on behalf of 46
women referred to at this point only as
Jane Doe the suit accuses Nygaard of
rape sexual assault sexual battery and
molestation of both young women and
children some as young as 14 none of it
has been proven in court and Nygaard has
not been charged in Canada or the u.s.
both are countries where attacks are
alleged to have taken place a
plaintiff's lawyer Lee sahaba says
Nygaard preyed on women he could coerce
or entice he often used the fact that he
runs in a fashion business to lure women
with the promise of a modeling career or
a job with it within his companies the
eccentric fashion moguls case was before
a judge again this week his lawyers were
trying to get the identities of the
women the judge will rule on that July
22nd but the plaintiff's lawyer says
handing over the names this early in the
process prior to discovery could open
them up to retribution by Nygaard and
they're fighting it we have decided to
protect our clients make sure that
they're safe he is our foremost concern
scandalous allegations no my guards
lawyer continues to deny his client did
anything wrong he says the plaintiffs
are hoping to cash in
but Global News spoke to another woman
Friday a Montrealer who says she was
sexually assaulted by Nygaard when she
was a young model starting out she's
considering joining the lawsuit our
evidence shows there are far far more
victims I mean men
and medical business now Pappas's even
though there have been reports about
Nygard treatment of women going back
years she claims to have evidence it
hasn't stopped Mike Armstrong Global
News Montreal a proposed class-action
lawsuit has been filed against the
estate of the gunman who killed 22
people in nova scotia last month
court documents show the lawsuit has
been felt on behalf of Nicholas Beaton
whose wife Kristin was killed and
families of some of the other victims
the suit is seeking damages for the
spouses children and/or parents of the
victims along with injuries and damage
caused by the gunman a judge must
approve the lawsuit before it can
proceed to trial
still ahead protesters say the
investigation was stalled in the murder
of a black man killed while jogging
two white men in Georgia a former police
officer and his son had been arrested
and charged with murder in the fatal
shooting of a black man
Gregory McMichael and his son Travis
went before a judge via videoconference
today
Ahmad Arbor II was shot and killed on
February 23rd then this week video was
released showing the shooting it sparked
a national outcry and prompted Georgia's
governor to launch an investigation the
suspects told police they thought Arbor
E was a burglary suspect Barbara's
family says he was unarmed and just out
for a jog just bigger than life just no
young man and he just today our burry
would have celebrated his 26th birthday
instead protesters almost all wearing
masks packed in front of the courthouse
to demand justice for his death they
believe local authorities stalled the
investigation Turkish prosecutors have
laid charges related to the daring
escape of Nissan's former boss seven
people are accused of helping Carlos
gonna get out of Japan for pilots and an
airline official are charged with
illegally smuggling a migrant to flight
attendants are accused of failing to
report a crime
gone who was arrested over allegations
of financial misconduct skipped bail
while awaiting trial in Japan last year
it's believed he was smuggled out of
house arrest in an instrument case he
then flew to Istanbul then on to Beirut
Japan has no extradition treaty with
Lebanon up next marking the victories of
one war while fighting a different
historic battle
that was the sound heard across London
today the rural air forces red arrows
flew in formation over the city to mark
the 75th anniversary of VE Day on May 8
1945 Allied forces accepted Nazi
Germany's surrender bringing an end to
the Second World War in Europe similar
fly pass took place across Britain to
honor veterans this anniversary would
have been commemorated with a huge
celebration but in the middle of a
pandemic that isn't possible millions of
people around the world including Second
World War veterans are isolating at home
but as Eric Swanson explains they came
up with new ways to mark the historic
day from nations that were brutally
attacked to those that were occupied to
the country that carries the burden for
starting at all the ceremonies to mark a
Victory in Europe day were as different
and somber as any in recent memory
Europeans not only stood silently they
stood alone Victory in Europe led to an
era of cooperation and trust for many
adversaries and yet the togetherness
that usually marks this day was missing
in Ottawa to the war memorial was a
stark backdrop for today's Remembrance
in this month of May 2020 let us
celebrate freedom and remain strong in
the face of adversity any of the happy
thousands who come to welcome peace the
celebrations we've come to take for
granted from the first jubilant events
when the Second World War ended to the
annual comrades in arms shoulder to
shoulder just weren't possible this year
they died to say we could live as free
people in a world of free nations they
risked all so our families and
neighborhoods could be safe they thought
I would make a good soldier norm Kirby
was just 17 when he became a good
soldier he was to attend the ceremonies
in Europe this year his image on the
poster commemorating the event still he
spoke recently about the importance of
the war he fought and survived in
Holland and we had quite a quite a
battle there and we lost lost a few guys
it was a war so devastating and
long-lasting that even in today's
challenging time it's hard to imagine
what they went through to walk beside a
guy knowing damn well that if he stepped
on the mine he would tell you he'd push
you out of the way he'd let the mind
blow up more than a million Canadians
and Newfoundlanders served in the war
more than 45,000 were killed they fought
and they died to defend the values that
we hold dear freedom peace and equality
and we are forever grateful
like many Canadians who liberated Europe
norm Kirby would never forget the
children whose future was changed on
this day seventy-five years ago it was
worth that worth it to see all of this
so don't ever think that it's a waste of
time it wasn't Eric Sorenson global news
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Robin Gill we leave you
tonight with five notes that carry
infinite meaning horn players came
together while staying apart for the
last post it is played to honor the lost
the fallen and the dead thank you for
watching good night